OPENING POSSESSION.THE
COVERAGE.
HUGHES, DISRUPTING THAT  RUSH.
RIGHT.
TRYING TO GET A SIDELINE.G DEVI
>> Bob: ONE-TIME DRIVE.
STOPPED BY   NEW JERSEY DEVILS
OVER.
HE LEAVES
GAMES, AND THEY DO SO IN A IS W
THEY GET A WIDE.HER.
SOME POINTS, AND HE FIRES
TOWARDS THE NETS.ON AKIRA SCHMI
RICK BOWNWNTHE BOX.
WRIST SHOT, HIT THE IRON.
REBOUND, RIGHT BETWEEN THE E
OUT FRONT.
IT'S PUT ON E WRISTER, FROM MIR
HEISKANE
IN THERE.
OFF-SPEED WRISTER.
GATHERS, BACK UP TOP.
OFF THE FEE DELPH
HIS ELBOW.OT, SCORE.
ROOPE
HINTZ, SHORESIDE.
WOW.
THEY SHOT OUT T SHOT, INTO JOE
BACK TO THE DEVILS LINE.REDLINE
HE FIRES IT IN. BACK IN IT.
JACK HUGHES,  AND
HERE THEY ARE, IN THE TO TRAFFI
JON GILLIES,  TOOK OVER.
THEY AT BATTLE.
TOP OF THE RIGHT-WING CIRCLE.
AS THE STARS
HUGHES, MADE IT LOOK SO
SEAMLESS.
IT WAS SO EASY.
NOTHING EASY ABOUT THIS THE
DOORSTEP, SPRAWLING, BRADEN
HOLTBY.
HE GOES A SNOW  START.
NONE BETTER IN THIS GAME IN THE
FIRST DOMINATION T FRONT.
SAVED. , THEY
ESTABLISH THEIR OWN. DALLAS,
ON TOP.